the Saw series started out as a fever
dream project for film students James
Wan and Leigh Whannell but has since
developed into a whole franchise of gore
the central villain jigsaw initially
presented himself as a non serial killer
who just wanted to force troubled people
into appreciating and fighting for their
lives but as the series went on his
games eventually made it clear that he
and his minions just wanted to see
people suffer as a result some
installments definitely turned out
better than others from worst to first
here's a ranking of all the Saw movies
so far saw 3d the final chapter by the
time the seventh piece of the jigsaw
puzzle came into play this series looked
almost nothing like the original in the
pic detective Hoffman was so busy
running around cleaning up his own
messes that the day's games seemed like
an afterthought meant only to fall a
formula in fact there were two major
group traps that were completely devoid
of value to the overarching plot who
ever thought it was necessary to have a
man rip all the skin off his back in 3d
might just be sicker than jigsaw there
were a couple elements of redemption
like dr. Gordon making a long-overdue
comeback to the series to tie a few
loose limbs and there was a kernel of
something interesting in play with the
fake jigsaw survivor at the center but
the movie was frustratingly disjointed
at Hoffman's Terminator style raid and
the police department laid waste to the
entire framework of jigsaws legacy saw 3
the third installment of the Saw series
was one of the most problematic for
several reasons for starters the victims
were completely sympathetic and even
less deserving of their fates than
anyone else submitting the father and
mother of a drunk driving victim to
torture trials just because they're not
grieving the way you might want them to
that's cruel even for jigsaw even worse
was the fact that the new traps for this
installment were unnecessarily gruesome
to the point of being unwatchable at
times and let's not forget about the
table-saw brain surgery we just had to
watch unfold sure it was a clever turn a
fortune that the person who was really
being tested it was Protege number 1
Amanda but the choice of victims here
seemed to exhaust the whole generous
Grim Reaper identity that jigsaw crafted
for himself in the previous picks making
saw 3 among the series slackers chapters
saw 6 whereas saw 5 managed to make
detective Hoffman interesting saw 6 did
not
he'd already killed off Strom and the
spate of drug addicts and other officers
who'd run afoul of jigsaw were all dead
as well Hoffman's victims list became
pretty arbitrary and ridiculous mark
this time he picked on a pair of
predatory loan sharks and one
particularly nasty insurance adjuster
who denied John Kramer coverage for some
experimental cancer treatments bearing
in mind the fact this movie was released
in the wake of the subprime mortgage
crisis it's understandable why the
filmmakers might try to get political
and punished greedy people however the
plot was still flimsy and under explored
and seemed extra gruesome just for the
sake of shock value combined with some
terrible acting and forced twists it
became stock schlock long before the
timer ran out the redeeming factor of
the movie that keeps it from landing
last on the list is that Hoffman's
voyeuristic copycat game in the
beginning was a pretty decent metaphor
for the Saw series as a whole saw for
for the fourth installment director
Darren Lynn Bozeman decided to delve
into John Kramer's wretched rationale by
bringing in his tragic story with his
wife into the picture along with another
secondary psycho to fill in the timeline
gaps as John Kramer took his leave of
the world but the central player of the
games
lieutenant rig was wholly undeserving of
his trial so what if he was passionate
about his job and missed out on a family
vacation or two the punishment never
really matched the crime in this series
but especially so for Rigg that said the
clever culmination of events at the end
was a fresh surprise that saved this
story the fact that jigsaw was still in
control of his crew even while lying
cold on an autopsy table was
delightfully bonkers and managed to
renew any fading interest in what was
next saw five by the time we got to the
fifth film it was detective Hoffman who
taken over jigsaws kill crew he was
sloppy enough to attract some heat from
on high in the form of FBI Special Agent
Strahm Strom was obsessively committed
to the cause of nailing his prime
suspect even after escaping his own
death trap by way of an ink pen
tracheotomy so the game of cat-and-mouse
that ensued between them was pretty epic
meanwhile the games that were afoot in
saw 5 were also a bit more precise and
interesting the victims of this round
weren't just helplessly being ripped to
shreds but instead at least pretended
use their brains before engaging those
mechanisms that would cause their
eventual demise the gore of the games
was mercifully dialed down a notch which
gave more room for the sound effects
team to fill in the blanks rather than
always leaning on graphic visuals to get
the job done this film's return to a
teamwork element in the games was
refreshing and the passionate pursuit of
strom culminated in a crushing twist
ending that was as jaw-dropping as
anything that came before it or after
saw to director Darren Lynne Bozeman
managed to avoid the sophomore slump
with the first sequel to saw in fact the
film gamely expanded the world that had
been established in the original and
offered a new vein of intrigue for the
subsequent sequels to float on the
backbone of the selected group of
victims stuck in a dirty doom house
where they're racing against the clock
to flesh out their own shared histories
was still there but the movie managed to
layer that element in a compelling
subplot about jigsaws arresting officer
detective Matthews and his missing son
and on top of that there was the
surprise return of Amanda what you
answered the question of what would
actually happen to those few who managed
to survive jigsaws game unlike some of
the other sequels the entire plot was
pretty polished and managed to give the
series some staying power
so movie 2 is the second best of the
series saw there was something very
artful about Shaw's approach to the
macabre that made the movie such an
indelible experience the puzzle pieces
of skin taken from victims bodies were
meant to be symbols of what was missing
from people's lives but they were also a
collective metaphor for the audience's
job of digesting everything that
happened in the film the small-scale
setting of two and a half people locked
in a bathroom playing a game of Clue for
their lives was surprisingly effective
and so were the whirly cam montage
tricks used to show off other terror
traps so saw opened the door to much
more interest in exploring the sick sad
world of jigsaw especially after it
ended on such a twist that it was
decidedly not game over the movie was
still far from perfect of course the
film had some moments of lazy acting and
low budget camera angling that are
pretty cringe-worthy upon review but
even if it didn't boast the slickest
cinematography known to hollywood saw
was still an original and very
disturbing abstraction for the art tours
to explore
and was executed with impressive
efficiency and invention for those
reasons it's still the best we'll just
have to wait and see if the next sequel
jigsaw manages to bring some life back
into the series but until then thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]